Herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich, herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen, herzlich, herzlich willkommen, herzlich, herzlich willkommen, herzlich, herzlich willkommen, herzlich, herzlich willkommen, herzlich, herzlich willkommen, herzlich, herzlich, herzlich, herzlich, herzlich, herzlich, herzlich, herzlich, herzlich, herzlich, herzlich, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, diesem Jahr jedes Intro machen wird. Richtig, ja. Stellt euch schon mal drauf ein. Er hat ein sechsstündiges Intro geschickt und wir haben gesagt, na, dann nehmen wir immer 20 Sekunden und verteilen das über das ganze Jahr. Denn wir haben eine Menge vor dieses Jahr. Wir werden hunderte Folgen machen. Ich bin auch genauso, ich bin immer genauso fatalistisch, wenn ein neues Jahr beginnt. Immer in diesem Jahr mache ich, und dann sage ich immer was, was ich niemals beibehalten werde.
Es ist ein bisschen so diese Neujahrsresolution, die man sich halt auch irgendwie vornimmt, aber es ist auch noch ein bisschen was anderes. Es ist dieses, keine Ahnung, weil ich auch Silvester habe, dieses Gefühl, jetzt ist ein harter Cut und dann wird alles anders und dann geht es genauso weiter.
Mein Vorsatz fürs neue Jahr, Erwartungen senken, runter damit, steh morgens auf, ich denke mir, wo sind meine Erwartungen, runter richtig, gerne mal ein Stück drücken, nee, mach gerne mal runter. Geht doch weiter runter. Geht noch, da geht noch, komm, komm, komm. Aber du meinst, die Erwartungen an dich und die Erwartungen ans Jahr? Generell, an das Leben, an die Leute, an die Welt, einfach Erwartungen senken. Einfach, wenn jemand sagt, willst du meinen Witz hören? Gedanklich, schön runter damit, richtig schön runter, kurbel da richtig, dass die richtig runtergehen, ganz nach unten. Was hattest du bisher für Erwartungen, wenn eine Person auf der Straße gegangen hat und gesagt, willst du mal einen Witz hören? Dann sage ich, jetzt kommt der fucking beste Witz, den ich je gehört habe. Weißt du, wo meine Erwartungen da waren? Ganz unten schon. Nee, nee, ich habe immer schon meine flache Hand auf mein Bäuchlein gelegt, weil ich dachte, jetzt wird das Bäuchlein gerieben.
Und Mund aufgerissen, um vorbereitet zu sein. Ja, schon mal den Kiefer ein bisschen durchspannen, weil ich dachte, jetzt wird schallend gelacht. Nein, richtig runter damit. Erwartungslimbo nenne ich das Ganze. Das ist mein Buchtitel, Erwartungslimbo, gut gelauntes neue Jahr. Du bist auf dem Cover mit so verschränkten Armen und so einem Pulli, wo die Ärmel zusammengeschaltet sind. Genau das, oder mit so einem kecken Gesichtsausdruck steige ich über die Limbo-Stange. So im Sinne von, das mache ich erst gar nicht mit dem Quatsch. Die hochgezogene Comedy-Augenbraue. Die hochgezogene Ralf Schmitz Comedy-Augenbraue und währenddessen irgendwie noch so ein Glasauge.uge-Coke-Light in der Hand. Irgendwie sowas, irgendwas, keine Ahnung. Aber sowas in der Richtung. Ich glaube, das verkauft sich gut. Also haltet die Augen offen, wenn das nächste Mal durch ein Hugendubel bummelt. Jetzt ist mein Lutschbonbon aufgelutscht. Wie lange war das jetzt? Das war jetzt, je nachdem wie viel wir rausschneiden von deinen Erzählungen von deiner Neujahrsfeier, drei Minuten ungefähr. Drei Minuten? Hä? Ist das ein Rekord? Ich habe zwanzig Minuten von meiner Neujahrsfeier erzählt. Ist das ein neuer Rekord in drei Minuten Fisherman's Friend aufgelutscht? Was ist der Weltrekord in Fisherman's Friend? Und wie stolz ist der Ehegatte des Rekordhalters auf seinen Gatten, der sagt Ich muss trainieren, Agathe, das ist mein Traum! Was macht Papa da? Die Kinder erkennen dich kaum noch, Heinrich, die sehen dich kaum noch zu, bekommen dich kaum noch zu Gesicht. Ja, weil du sie nicht zugucken lässt, wie ich das Fisherman's Friends auch. Diese spezielle Technik, die Hermannstechnik. Wo er es als erster Mensch geschafft hat, seinen gesamten Rachenraum zu nutzen, um das Bonbon auf... Weil du weißt ja, je mehr Oberfläche, desto mehr Bonbon wird entfernt.
Das heißt, er schafft es mit seiner Zunge, den gesamten Rachenraum einzug.
Kann man den Gaumen nicht eh mit benutzen, wenn du von unten eine schnelle Reibetechnik quasi mit der Zunge unten und der Gaumen wird von oben?
Ja, das war bisher die Technik, aber Heinrich hat es revolutioniert, so eine Kreistechnik, wirklich so eine Globustechnik, überall alles ausgenutzt haben. Mega. Gibt es da, wie beim Schach, ich bin ja beim Schachfieber, gibt es da auch so die italienische, der italienische Anfang des Lutschens? Ja, klar. Es gibt ja, also ich rotiere ja Fisherman's Friend immer. Du machst den ungarischen, den ungarischen Roller. Ich mache den ungarischen Roller, indem ich nämlich Längs rotiere. Ich glaube, du bist jemand, der rotiert. Was ist das Unterschied, das andere von längs? Wängs? Längs? Längs und Brengs, Länge, Breite? Ja, drüben. Längs rüber. Längs rüber, quer? Ich weiß es nicht, aber das ist auf jeden Fall meine Herangehensweise, aber du bist ein erfahrener Lutscher. Ich bin ein sehr, sehr erfahrener Lutscher.
Ich lutsche das weg und ich habe auch generell, glaube ich,
es gab in meinem Leben so vielleicht so
drei, vier Tage, wo
mein Gaumen nicht wund war.
Es gibt ja viele so Sachen,
wo der Gaumen einfach wund
wird danach irgendwie und
dann sagst du, ach jetzt sollte ich da mal wieder ein bisschen
zu ruck, oder? Kann ich dir auch Hornhaut dann bilden eigentlich?
Interessante Frage eigentlich.
Hornhaut eigentlich nur außen, aber
innen vielleicht auch. Vielleicht ist die komplette
Ich glaube, deswegen haben die dann bildende Schleim, ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber bist du denn generell so bei Schokobons? Biss Lutschaut und Kauer? Oder einfach im Schlucken, wie in der Tülle. War das eigentlich... Direkt mit einem Glas Wasser. Mit einem Glas Wasser. Ich glaube, daran erkennt man Aliens. Wenn du Leuten in der Fußgängerzone so einen Schokobong gibst und die spülen das runter als so ein Glas Wasser. Ja, das ist eigentlich ein schöner Science-Fiction-Film. Ich glaube, mein Mitbewohner ist ein Alien. Warum, hä? Hä, will jemand Schokobong... Naja, immer wenn wir Schokobongs essen, dann wirft er seinen Kopf in den Nacken, haut mit der flachen, hansige Schokobong rein und schttelt ins Wasser. Und dann steckt er auf den Tisch und sagt, ah! Und hat dann so einen Gesichtsausdruck, als hätte er irgendwas ganz saures. Ah! Okay, wow, los geht's! Wo sind die Girls? Peter, ich weiß nicht, das ist ganz merkwürdig. Petra 3 heißt ja auch, wenn wir mal drauf kommen können. Aber ja, weil ich nehme mir mal vor zu lutschen, um halt möglichst langanhaltend das Geschmackserlebnis präsent im Mund zu haben und verfalle dann auch immer ins Kauen. Wo man auch merkt, dass ich so wenig Selbstdisziplin habe, nicht mehr wenn ich mir vornehme, den Schokobon zu lutschen. Also nicht nur, ich habe mir erst vorgenommen, es nicht zu essen, durchbrochen. Erst hast du vorgenommen, es nicht zu kaufen. Ja, also da sind mehrere Disziplinmauern durchbrochen worden. Eigentlich wolltest du um 22 Uhr nicht immer noch mal zum Lidl gehen. So, war da. Aber du hast es nicht den Schokobon kaufen, habe sie gekauft. Wollte nicht alle auf einmal essen, habe sie alle gegessen. Wollte wenigstens lutschen, um länger was davon zu haben, nein, egal. Nein, schön runtergeschlungen. Ich versuche ja immer, der Länge nach zu trennen und dann im Mund die Hälften. Wie, zu trennen? Hast du ein Messer, ein Hümmelchen? Ne Zähne, ich habe Mundmesser, da kann ich den Chocoban der Länge nach teilen, dann versuche ich die Hälften gegeneinander zu rotieren, sodass, und da sind wir wieder, so eine Art Diabolo-Form entsteht, so eine Art Jojo-Form. Nicht mal das haben wir 2020 hinter uns gelassen. Um sie dann noch zu beissen. Also, ja, aber ehrlich gesagt, wild. Seit es die weißen Chocobons gibt, hat sich das Thema eh erledigt, glaube ich. Sind die in Braun? Endlich den nächsten Level. Die sind in. Die sind in. Aber das ist ja vor allem der weiße Schokolade nochmal um den normalen Chocobon rum. Ja. Das ist ja so ein bisschen der Kuhflecken-Moment, wenn man merkt, nee, nee, nicht weisse Schokolade statt dunkler, sondern beides. Selbst Kinderschokolade ist ein bisschen disziplinierter als ich, weil ich wollte mir dann neulich Schoko Fresh kaufen, gibt es nicht mehr. Die selber haben gesagt, wir nehmen uns heute nicht mehr zum... Was, wirklich jetzt? Schoko Fresh gibt es schon ewig nicht mehr und was es schon viel länger nicht mehr gibt, ist Happy Hippo. Ja, aber Happy Hippo ist ja der Vorgänger, der Vorgänger vom Schoko Fresh, der direkte Vorgänger. Schoko Fresh ist nur ein bisschen der Weltmännische. Das ist eine sehr schlampige Evolution, das ist so eine Dino zu Huhn Evolution, wo man im Nachhinein sagt, wirklich? Schoko Fresh ist sozusagen Alphabet, was Alphabet zu Google ist, ist Schoko Fresh zu Happy Hippo. Nein, aber allein die Tatsache, dass es gekühlt werden muss, heißt, dass es eine ganz andere Art von Snack ist. Ah, Moment. Happy Hippo musste nicht gekühlt werden. War das diese helle Waffel? Happy Hippo war diese, ja, diese Art Schneemann-Form. Nee, Nien-Pferd-Form. Ja. Warum gibt man diesem Gebäck eine distinkte Form, damit du dann sagst, er sieht so ähnlich aus wie eine Birne? Und das wurde aber im klassischen Hanuta-Regal gelagert, also war nicht gekühlt. Also Schoko Fresh, da sind wir wo ganz anders. Da ist ja Kinder Country, Kinder Maxi King eher näher dran. Das ist die Maxi King-Pingui-Ecke. Ja, ja, das ist was ganz anderes. Ja, das war was. Das war was ganz anderes. Na gut, sorry. Also da bist du jetzt wirklich ein paar Mal falsch abgebogen. Ich hatte ja letztes Jahr so einen paranoiden Moment.
Oh, dieses letztes Jahr. Immer diese, das war jetzt nicht der Witz, den du gemacht hast.
Nein.
Aber wie man sich hasst, wie man seine Verwandten auch dann hasst in diesen WhatsApp-Gruppen, wo dann der Onkel schreibt, ha, dann sehen wir uns nächstes Jahr.
Ja, nee, wird direkt blockiert, wird direkt blockiert.
Ich hatte eine Angstphase, weil ich habe irgendwann keine Kinder-Countries mehr gesehen.
Nicht, dass ich sie hätte kaufen wollen, aber ich habe sie gern um mich. Also es gibt so manche Produkte, die habe ich... Du bist froh, dass sie da sind. Und da ist es ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen eine urmenschliche Stapellust erfüllen. Ich glaube, der Mensch hat Stapellust, der will Dinge so aufschichten. Eine Lasagne kommt gut an, weil das ist so schön gestapelt. Waffeln aller Art. Das ist ein bisschen so wie das Beklebowski-Syndrom vielleicht, wo er am Ende ja sagt, der Erzähler, der Cowboy, sagt ja, ist es nicht gut zu wissen, dass es ihn gibt, den Dude? Genau so ist es. Es ist beruhigend zu wissen, dass es so jemanden gibt, der die Probleme, die auf ihn zu prassen, einfach wegignorieren kann und float. Ja, das sind so Dinge, wenn du hörst, ein Produkt wird nicht mehr weitergeführt und du bist traurig, obwohl du es seit sieben Jahren nicht mehr gekauft hast. Und trotzdem bist du traurig, weil du so dieses Frucht-Ufo, dieses Joghurt-Frucht-Ufo, das wurde lange abgesetzt und da war ein Stich in die Magengegend, obwohl ich es schon lange nicht mehr gekauft habe. Jetzt kommt es zurück, aber ohne die UFO-Form.
Er fasst sich die Hände an die Stirn. Ich bin da.
Da gibt es Leute, die studieren den ganzen Tag Marketing.
Also jetzt kommt mal ein kleiner Rant raus
gegen die Marketingwelt, weil die wollen uns das Geld
aus der Tasche ziehen und geben fast nichts zurück.
Die studieren Marketing, also so doof, da muss man ein Studierter für haben. Ich fühle mich selber schmutzig. Ich müsste duschen. Du musst immer so moderieren, als würdest du jemandem, der noch nie Podcast-Ufo gehört hat, eine Folge anmoderieren. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber selbst dann, die sagen, okay, Leute, die Leute haben das Frucht-Ufo geliebt, es muss zurückkommen, aber in einer hohen Becher. Das ist wie Pringles kurz abzusetzen und wiederzubringen, aber ungestapelt. Ja, oder halt so wie so Oblaten, einfach ganz flach. So Pringles sind back, aber nicht in dieser geschwungenen Form, sondern einfach ganz flach. Ich habe neulich ein bisschen reverse-engineert, ich hatte nämlich noch Chips da, und wenn ich irgendwas da habe in meiner Wohnung, esse ich das sofort. Wenn ich da irgendwie Süsskram habe oder etwas salziges, halt so typische Snacks, die sind wirklich am gleichen Abend, egal wie viel es ist, ich habe da kein Maß, sind am gleichen Abend noch komplett weg. So, dann war irgendwie Silvester, meine 100-Mann- starke Feiertruppe, weg. So, und dann habe ich noch so ein paar Chips da gehabt, habe die dann gegessen. Dann dachte ich mir, nee, weil wann bekomme ich am meisten Bock immer auf Chips und bin sauer, wenn sie nicht da sind? Richtig, wenn man irgendwie eine Doku guckt über die Chipsproduktion oder wenn man Jumbo Schreiner, J vor dieser großen Trommel oder einfach in so einer Fabrik ist, wo dann so ein grosses Behältnis vor ihm ist, wo dann schon mal so fertige Chips frittiert werden und er steht daneben und sagt, das ist ein Chip, wie er mir gefällt, gross, saftig und dann ist er beistet da rein und man denkt, boah, jetzt Chips, ey. Also habe ich diese Chips-Tüte gehabt, aber zuerst und dachte mir dann, jetzt machst du so eine Doku an. Perfekt. Dann hast du noch mehr Begründung. Und die hast du dann schon weggeschaut und musst dir nicht zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt schauen, wo du dann wieder Chips losbekommst. Richtig. Es ist auf vielen Arten cleverer als ich selbst bin. Das ist echt perfekt. Das ist richtig gut. Das fand ich richtig gut. Ich habe also diese Chips da gehabt und dann habe ich mir eine Doku angeguckt. Und da kam die, das ist aber keine Doku, sondern es war halt so ein typischer Galileo-Beitrag. Also was sind die besten Chips, die vom Discounter oder die teuren? Natürlich hatte ich diese billigen da vor mir liegen. Und die kamen dann gar nicht gut weg in dem Beitrag. Da stand dann, es fing erst cool an und auch nett. Und irgendwie fing dann, stand dann wirklich daneben und gesagt, die sind kross und saftig. Da habe ich mir, oh ja, die sind wirklich kross und saftig. Und am Ende des Beitrags war, ja, dann haben sie auch wirklich meine Packung in die Kamera gezeigt, aus der ich gerade schon eine halbe Stunde gefressen habe, und haben gesagt, oh, was haben wir denn hier drauf? Und dann war da so ein Lebensmittelforscher, Laborant, Doktor, irgendwas, hat dann halt gesagt, ah, nee, da sind Emulgatoren drin und folgendes, genau, Hafer-Extrakt oder sowas, das Hefe-Extrakt, das ist ganz furchtbar, sehr ungesund, sollte man nicht benutzen. Die teureren Varianten haben die ja dann nicht und die haben eine echte Hefe und bla bla bla bla. Wo man sich dann schon bereut, dass man das nicht vorher gesagt bekommen hat. Ich finde es gut, wie in einer Erzählung das Niveau sich schlagartig verringert hat von Doku auf Galileo-Beitrag. Einfach so, ja, dann schreibe ich mir eine Doku an. Aber ich finde es eine gute Idee. Eigentlich sollte man immer, wo man etwas kaufen oder essen kann, auch eine Doku darüber zeigen. Zum Beispiel, als ich studiert habe in München, gab es gegenüber der LMU gab es den verrückten Eismacher. Der war verrückt und der hat ganz viele verschiedene Eissorten hergestellt und der war so verrückt, dass Galileo gesagt hat, verrückt genug für die Sendung, wir gehen da mal hin und haben einen Beitrag über diesen Eisladen gemacht, weil da gab es dann so Senfeis und Weisswursteis und solche Sachen. Ah, ich weiß, der ist auch gegenüber von der Pinakothek oder nicht, der ist in der Nähe zumindest. Ja, ja, grob. Und dieser in dem Verrückten Eismacher lief den ganzen Tag der Galileo-Beitrag über den Verrückten Eismacher. Auch außen in den Fenstern war ein Fernseher, einfach um zu zeigen, wir waren bei Galileo. Das heißt, wenn du da anstandest... Um jetzt den Bogen komplett voll zu bekommen, den Bogen zu schlagen, in einem Hotel in Berlin, was ich sehr mag, läuft die ganze Big Lebowski. Da läuft 24-7 auf einem Bildschirm, aber auch nur auf einer Etage läuft Big Lebowski. Eigentlich müsste in jeder Bowlinghalle den ganzen Tag Big Lebowski laufen. Ich finde, es sollte genau auf jedem Fernseher der Welt so defaultmäßig Big Lebowski ausgedauften. Richtig. Und du machst den an und beim Anmachen machst du Big Lebowski aus. Genau, ja. Das hört mir eigentlich mal so an LG-Pitchen oder irgendwie so ein Fernsehersteller, die sagen einfach, guck mal diese Schwarz. Was ist das denn? Wer hat sich das denn ausgedacht, diese Schwarz? Das ist umweltschonend. Wenn der aus ist, ja, ja, nee, aber wenn du statt Schwarz ... Was ist besser als Schwarz? Hey, da können die auch von ihre Plastiktüten in diesen Raum so werfen. Ja, aber was ist besser als Schwarz? Fast alles. Fast alles. Und was ist besser als alles? Big Lebowski. Das heißt, statt Schwarz einfach Lebowski laufen lassen. Einfach den ganzen Tag.
Ja, ich finde es gut. Also das finde ich, es macht so Spaß. Ich bin auch viel öfter aus meinem Hotelzimmer gekommen, einfach weil ich wissen wollte, wo läuft, auf welcher Stelle ist gerade Big Lebowski? Was macht der Dude gerade? Ich glaube, der Nebenher-Film ist eh unterrepräsentiert.
Also jeder akzeptiert, dass man Musik nebenbei hört.
Im Supermarkt
läuft den ganzen Tag Musik, irgendwas
so nebenbei, niemand sagt, Ruhe, Ruhe, Ruhe,
Ruhe, Duallipa läuft gerade, Ruhe,
tu die
Conflakes weg,
ich will das Lied hören.
Das macht auch keiner.
Die Comedy-Figur, die Kunstperson
Florentin, mir ist aufgefallen,
dass wenn du Dinge referenzierst, sind es natürlich die, die du gerade hörst. Ja, klar, natürlich. Also hörst du gerade Dua Lipa? Was heißt, ich höre Dua Lipa? Wie gesagt, wir schreiben auf Instagram aktiv. Was heißt, wir schreiben? Du schreibst aktiv. Ich bin Wortführer, sagen wir mal so. Ich leite das Ganze. Aber ja, von daher, nee, ist eine tolle Nachbuchskünstlerin. Für mich Künstler 2020. Willst du auch Künstlerin 2021? Nee, aber 2022 dann wieder. Das ist so, die macht jetzt erst mal eine Pause, legt sich das mal hin. Die legt sich jetzt erst mal schlafen. Leg dich mal hin, du lieber. Die nimmt so wirklich so die eine Bettdecke in die Hand und rollt sich dann so ganz oft ein, so wie so ein Burrito. So richtig schön eingerollt, wie so ein Crepe. Finde ich super. Wie so ein schöner Crepe mit so einer Bananenfüllung. Ja, das finde ich gut. Es sollte eigentlich nur ein Nebenbeifilme geben und der Trend geht aber wieder hin, habe ich das Gefühl. Weil der Trend geht dahin, dass man Netflix mittlerweile anmacht und zumindest bei mir überlegt sich jetzt, gucke ich diesen Film jetzt. will ich diesen Film jetzt gucken als Hauptaktivität oder mache ich den anderen nebenbei was anderes zu machen, zum Beispiel kochen oder sowas. Aber glaubst du, Filme werden in Zukunft auch produziert mit dem Hintergedanken, dass sie als Nebenbeifilme funktionieren müssen, dass man Szenen oft wiederholt. und sie angekommen, da habe ich schon lange. Yes! Zeig's ihnen! Zeig's ihnen, Stefan! Ohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohohoho, zwei Hände hochnimmt, dann der Drache so einen Schlenker macht und dann hohoho! Vielleicht sogar runterfällt, Spannung, Spannungmusik und dann holt ihn der Drache aber nochmal hoch. Und dann wieder, und Bernard Herrmann oder wer auch immer geht wieder mit den Geigen steil. Weil da kannst du ja gleich mal deinen Netflix-Koffer aufmachen und ich habe ja gehört, Netflix ... Meinen leeren. Meinen komplett leeren. Sehr, sehr kompliziertes Zahlenschloss, aber dann leer, so muss ein Koffer sein. Und ich habe ja gehört, Netflix... Mein Lehren. Sehr, sehr kompliziertes Zahlen schloss, aber dann leer. So müssen Koffer sein. Und ich habe gehört, dass sie mehr in Richtung Smartphone produzieren wollen, sprich nah ran riesengroßer Text, riesengroße Gesichter, damit du das auf deinem kleinen 3-Zoll-Handy auch genießen kannst. Und geniessen werden auf der Kle kleiner, habe ich auch das Gefühl. Ja, das ist die technische La-Ola-Welle, die durch die Generationen geht, immer kleiner, größer. Wir haben uns auf die Sinuskurve geeignet. Nee, das ist die La-Ola-Welle, klein, groß und wir sind gerade am Höhepunkt. Ich habe das Gefühl, unsere Forschungen sind cool, aber unsere Benennungen sind immer so ein bisschen so neigen ins Populistische. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir, wir, ach, du mit deinen Beispielen immer. Lollipop-Theorie, der Donut. Ich glaube, ich muss mich hier nicht kritisieren lassen, ich war der Erfinder des Cookies. Wenn du deine User fragst, Cookies deaktivieren, wer sagt, ja, Cookies deaktivieren? Ich hasse Cookies. Jeder sagt, ja bitte Cookies aktivieren, natürlich aktivieren. Und wir wissen alles über dich, wir wissen alles über dich, wir haben nämlich die Kekskrümelspur durchs ganze Internet von dir. Frage, wie heißt das, was man entlehren kann? Da gibt es auch in dieser Cookie-Welt gibt es etwas, das kenne ich nur geschrieben, Cash, Cash, Cash, Cash, Cash, Cash, Cash, Kache, niemand weiß es. Ich lese es als Kache, immer noch, weil es zum ersten Mal als Kind habe ich das gesehen. Kache, ja. Und da habe ich jetzt nicht an die magischen anderen Sprachen auf dieser Welt gedacht, die es noch gibt, sondern habe gedacht, ja Kache. Aber allein das wäre doch ein Sketch, oder? Irgendwie so ein Programmierer tippt so rum und sagt, du, Paul, kannst du mal ganz kurz kommen? Ich habe hier ein Problem mit dem Cash.
Ach so, ja, den Kachel musst du dann so machen.
Dann holen sie noch einen anderen Programmierer hinzu, der immer Cache sagt.
Und sie bleiben konsistent.
Es gibt zu viele Möglichkeiten, das ist auch das Problem.
Entschuldigung, Marina, kannst du auch mal kurz gucken?
Nächster Programmierer kommt ran und alle sagen das anders.
Aber niemand geht darauf ein.
Niemand sagt, Entschuldigung, das heißt Cash,
sondern alle sagen ihr Wort über den gesamten Sketchen weg. Und ich glaube, vier, fünf Likes sind drin. Achso, ich hatte vier, fünf Minuten. Nee, das muss zwanzig Minuten sein. Das funktioniert nur auf Länge, da muss man richtig rein donnern dem Zuschauer. Und dann, weil wir ja schon weiterdenken, Netflix, grosse Gesichter, grosser Text, immer ganz nah dran, damit es auch so kleine, so einem Zoll Displays funktioniert. Ja, wahnsinnig laut, damit auch, wenn man das Handy so in der U-Bahn von sich weghält, damit es funktioniert, also dieses Tastengeklapper, wenn die da programmieren, Ohren betäubend laut, richtig hoch, Udi, hoch, lauter, lauter, lauter. Laudo, mach die Regler auf. Udo, mach den Regler auf, du, Gain, mach den Gain rauf. So stelle ich mir das vor bei der Netflix Headquarters. Es ist genauso. Udo, gib Gast, Mensch. Im Prinzip optimiert dann für eine Apple-Watch. Im Grunde eigentlich schon. Ja, die kippen dann noch ein bisschen Kohle in die Soundmaschine bei Netflix, um das so mal richtig Gast. Auch in La-Ola-Welle habe ich beobachtet bei Bildschirmgrössen, also so Kino. Wurde ja flacher lange, also war ja erst so 4 zu 3, dann 16 zu 9, wurde immer breiter, breiter, breiter, dann ist das Cinescope, irgendwann war man dann bei 1 zu, weiß ich auch jetzt nicht. Und jetzt mittlerweile ist man wieder IMAX, so die neueste Form, geht wieder zurück, weil es halt ein bisschen so immersiver ist.
Du bist halt immer noch, wenn du halt oben und unten nicht unbedingt das Ende siehst, hast du halt noch das Gefühl, du bist mehr im Geschehen. Ja, und irgendwann gehst du wieder ins Hochformat. Und jetzt langfristig gehen wir wieder zurück ins Hochformat, so wo es dann wahrscheinlich so 1830 gewesen wäre, wenn es da schon Filme gegeben hätte. Ja, und die Hochformat und dann glaube ich kommt irgendwann die Acht. Das sind irgendwann so zwei Kreise, die so zu einem gewissen Teil überlappen und das ist dann die neue Form, sowas in der Richtung. Aber eigentlich im Grunde ist es ja eigentlich dumm, weil du hast ja zwei Augen, warum nicht zwei Bilder? Ja, 3D. So, 3D-Kino. Weiter, weiter, weiter, ne, gibt's schon. Weiter, 4D-Kino, 5D, 6D, lauter, lauter, lauter, vier D-Kino gibt es im Freizeitpark, sind aus, exklusiv, da gibt es vier D-Kinos im Freizeitpark, ich habe nicht genau verstanden, warum.
Wir waren doch in New York in dem Kino, wo ein Wasser ins Gesicht gespritzt wurde und wo der Stuhl rotiert hat, wo du dich verletzt hast.
Nee, viele Probleme gehabt. Und ich nicht wusste, ob du mit der Rolle gehst und sagst, ich bin angeschossen, Hilfe, Hilfe.
Du wusstest nicht, ob ich mit der Rolle gehst und sagst, ich wurde angeschossen, Hilfe, Hilfe.
Du wusstest nicht, ob ich Babydrager war so emotional, deswegen geweint habe oder weil der Sitz mich mit dem Kopf gegen den Vordermann geschlodert hat.
Ich wusste nicht, ob die Flüssigkeit in meinem Gesicht meine Tränen waren oder ob es mir ins Gesicht gespritzt wurde.
Ich wusste nicht, weine ich gerade, bin ich emotional gerade?
Ja, und nicht wegen einer Regenszene, sondern weil die beim ersten Date sich Wasser eingeschenkt, weil der Kellner Wasser eingeschenkt hat und das hat mir ins Gesicht gespritzt. Einfach so das ist die Zukunft des Kinos, darfst du noch im Wasser sein? Pfff, voll ins Gesicht. Aber ohne Scheiss, für so Filme so nacht-de-Kanone-mässig perfekt.
Ja, grossartig.
Eigentlich für solche Filme wäre das perfekt.
Aber dass man einfach so eine Fontäne Wasser ins Gesicht bekommt. Und dann, aber das andere Extrem war beim Schießen. Da gab es irgendwann so ein Verfolgungsverlagt mit Schusswechsel. Ja. Und da kam so ein kleiner, so ein Pustel. Genau, ja. So in den Rücken. Aber dann wieder ein Glas Wasser. Das war toll. Alles Snacks verloren auf dem Weg. Tolles Snacks gab es da, viele Cheesy Bites, Laugenbrezel, Pressel Bites, alles nass geschleudert. Alles nass halt nass. Mit diesem ekligen Wasser. Aber das ist nicht 4D-Kino, das ist 3D-Motion Seeds. Oder nicht? Oh, wenn du das sagst, klingt gut. Ist die vierte Dimension auf Wasser ins Gesicht gespritzt bekommen? Ich glaube, es ist nicht auch, also es gibt die ersten drei Dimensionen, dann gibt es die Motion Seed-Dimension. Erklär mir mal Dimensionension. Ja, das ist halt, ja, waschoke, das ist ja, muss das so ein bisschen... Ich habe nämlich, es gibt diese tollen Videos von, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ist das Weiss, Videos, wo ein Mensch, ein Experte auf dem Gebiet, ich glaube fünf verschiedenen Altersgruppen, wo Expertenstufen ein Thema erklärt. Da gibt es einen Physiker, der sich auch auf Dimensionen und so fokussiert hat. Und der erklärt erst einem Kleinkind, einem Kindergartenkind Dimensionen bis hin zu einem Experten. Und man erwischt sich ja selber, wenn man so mit hochgezogenen Augenbrauen das Video anfängt. Wie weit komme ich mit? Nee, und überlegt, ja gut, erklären wir es mal dem Kind. Und dann fragt der Forscher, was sind Dimensionen? Und das Kind gibt eine komplett richtige, coole Aussage, auf die ich so niemals gekommen wäre. Und natürlich habe ich das Video nicht zu Ende geguckt, weil das macht einen ja fertig. Mit meinem Kindergartenkind bin ich schon raus. Ja, ne, ist schön schon. Aber man merkt auch immer so, dass die letzte Stufe der Experte, der fühlt sich immer nicht so gut damit, jetzt erklärt zu bekommen von dem noch grösseren Experten. Der ist immer so ja, ja, ich weiß schon. Warum habt ihr mich nicht gefragt, das Kleinkind zu erzählen? Wahrscheinlich fragen die mehrere Experten an und je nachdem, wer zusagt, müssen die halt willkürlich sagen, du bist jetzt der grössere Experte als der andere und dann muss der sich von seinem Kollegen erklären lassen, was er herausgefunden hat in der Forschung. Und beim Kindergartenkind? Fragen die das Claire, was das Kindergartenkind oder das dümmste Kindergartenkind? Weiß ich nicht, fotogen. Allein, dass ihr, als ich gerade das erzählt habe, dass ich nicht wiedergeben konnte, was das Kindergartenkind gesagt hat, spricht auch Bände. Ich glaube, es hat aber einigermaßen eine gute Definition von Dimension gegeben. Aber Zeit. Wie gesagt, also ich glaube, auch so ein Dimensionsforscher, wenn der am Ende sagt, du, das war alles falsch, sagt er, ach ja, ist ja auch nicht so wichtig, oder? Ist das so wichtig? Wenn du eine Rakete baust und jemandem dir, du hast aber alles falsch berechnet, dann sagst du, fuck, die waren gar nicht auf dem Mond, die waren in Nürnberg, die dachten und die sind auf dem Mond. Ach nee, die haben nie die Stratosphäre verlassen. Aber wir waren schnell in Nürnberg, das muss man sagen. Wirklich sehr schnell. Schneller als der Zug. Ach so, ja, das ist blöd. Aber als Dimensionsforscher sagst du ja, im Grunde ist das doch auch egal.
Ja, diese theoretische Physik, die ist so, die Leute, die trauen sich nicht, echte Berechnungen durchzuführen, sondern es sind so Berechnungen so, wenn es falsch ist. Ach, mir macht es Spaß. Ich mag das. Und vor allem, in den meisten Fällen, wenn es widerlegt wird, sind die schon tot. Ideal. Also wenn es entweder nachgegeben ist. Es ist so kompliziert, dass du drei Generationen brauchst, um es zu widerlegen. Ist ideal. Oder zu beweisen. Aber dann willst du ja eher, dass es falsch ist. Weil du willst ja nicht tot sein, wenn du gefeiert wirst als der neue Einstieg. Klar will ich tot sein, wenn ich gefeiert werde. Ist so ideal. Wenn ich gefeiert werde, will ich nur im Leben sein. Ja, aber der Druck ist zu hoch. Was machst du als nächstes? Muss er nichts mehr machen. Du kannst in dem... Genau, du kannst ja dann fast nichts mehr machen. Jetzt wieder wie dieser Higgs-Typ. Der Physiker, der hat dieses Higgs-Boson sich ausgedacht und hat gesagt, das ist doch geil, ich finde es geil, ich finde es geil. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, aber weiss man nicht, ob es gibt. Und irgendwann wurde es bewiesen, dass es gibt, aber der hat seitdem auch nichts mehr gemacht, der kann jetzt nicht einen Podcast rausbringen und sagen, hier, ich spreche über lustige Anekdoten aus dem Alltag, weil alle sagen, nee, es wird immer gemessen an dem Erfolg des Higgs-Bosons. Du bist immer nur so gut wie dein letztes Higgs-Boson. Ja, genau. Farsi. Ja, genau. Was ist dein letztes Higgs-Boson? Interview mit John Gnar, damals, dem Bürgermeister von Reykjavik. Deine letzte große Nummer? Das war meine letzte große Nummer. Bürgermeisterinterview von Reykjavik. Das war lustig, das war richtig gut und seitdem eigentlich geht es nur noch bergab. Seitdem muss ich mich, alles was ich mache, jeden kleinen Limerick, den ich schreibe, jedes Essay, jedes, seht's nochmal von der Seite, Essay muss ich mich an dem messen lassen und ich fall durch. Ich fall durch jedes Mal. Einerseits meine, nee, ihr seht schon von der richtigen Seite Essays, die ich immer schreibe.
Ist schon alles so richtig, wie ihr es macht.
Ist schon alles so richtig, wie ihr es macht. Muss auch mal kommen, so ein Essay.
Einfach so, passt schon. Weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, komm, weiter, weiter, nicht stehen bleiben, weiter geht's, weiter geht's, weiter geht's.
Ich will euch gar nicht aufhalten, ich will euch gar nicht aufhalten.
So, habt ihr gelesen dieses fünf Minuten an der Überschrift?
Nope, wir sind hier schon zu Ende.
Macht, genießt eure viereinhalb Minuten, die habt ihr jetzt frei. Ihr habt euch fünf Minuten für den Artikel freigenommen, habt jetzt Freizeit. Aber ich muss auch sagen, das neue Jahr fing für mich toll an, weil ich war live dabei beim Sturm aufs Kapitol, weil ich habe natürlich, folge ich Klaus Kleber auf Twitter und er hat sofort geschrieben, jetzt hier ein Ende einschalten und ich so, hell yeah. Ja, und dann habe ich mir wieder, weil ich mich an die Wahlnacht erinnert habe, auch geschmacklich, habe ich mir wieder bei Pizza hat, bei Pizza hat, halt mit so American Pizza eingedeckt, so in lächerlichen Mengen, und habe die ganze Nacht bis vier Uhr CNN geguckt und dem Sturm aus Kapitol verfolgt. Und man muss ja wirklich sagen, wie uncool das in mir auch ist, diese kleine Stimme, die doch in mir ist, die ist nicht rational und die sehe ich auch nicht so, aber die existiert, die sagt, yes, ein Ereignis, was man verfolgen kann. Weil so natürlich existiert uns Menschen in Sensationsgier. Ich habe mir auch, also dieses Ereignis hat mich nochmal ganz anders auf alle historischen Ereignisse zurückblicken lassen, weil die hatten ja mega Spaß. Die hatten ja mega Bock, also denen hat es ja richtig Spaß gemacht. Es wurden nämlich Memes gemacht und so, und die hatten Spaß, es war, ja, außer die eine Frau, die dann am Ende interviewt wurde, die dann ja klar, gut, aber die meisten, die haben gelacht, die haben posiert, die haben Selfies gemacht. Wenn ich jetzt an sowas zurückdenke wie die Stürme auf die Bastille oder so, wo ich dachte, krass Krieg, Revolution, wahrscheinlich hatten die einen mega geilen Nachmittag. Einfach so, klar, gehen da Leute drauf, aber an sich war das wahrscheinlich alles lustiger und lustig hier, du auch da, krass cool. Ja, aber auch so, vielleicht war das alles gar nicht so ernst damals. Nee, und erstens das und zweitens auch wussten die zu dem Zeitpunkt schon, wie wichtig das ist. Weil ich hatte das Gefühl, an dem Abend hatte ich noch nicht das Gefühl, ich nehme mir gerade an Zeithistorie teil. Ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, so, ja, schon krass alles und mega uncool und holy shit, was passiert da alles in den USA und Leuten geschrieben. Aber ich hatte jetzt nie das Gefühl, es so eingeordnet zu haben wie dann Experten drei Tage danach. Und ich dachte, beim Schnurr und die Bastille dachten die meisten wahrscheinlich einfach so. Also ich glaube nicht, dass da schon Leute mit der Weitsicht dann dabei waren. Hat es einen Wikipedia-Artikel? Ich weiß nicht, ob es einen Wikipedia-Artikel hat. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Das wäre so meine Sorge. Wenn ich dabei wäre, würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen, jetzt habe ich mal die Möglichkeit, Live-Geschichte festzuhalten und würde live einen Wikipedia-Artikel schreiben, Mit dem, ich gehe jetzt die Treppe hoch, ich biege jetzt links ab, so wird hier so einen Wikipedia-Artikel mal aus der ersten Person geschrieben. Nicht immer so nur dieses, oh, vor 60 Jahren, vor 4000 Jahren hat irgendwie Kaiser Romulus das und das, sondern so, nee, hier links, ich gucke zum Fenster raus, sehe das, mal richtig gelebte Geschichte, finde ich gut. Ob Remus Vorschlag war, Remus und Romulus? Aber er hat sich nicht durchgesetzt? Ich glaube schon. Weil Romulus gesagt hat, auch Roy und Siegfried, wahrscheinlich auch eher. Ich bin mittlerweile bei jedem Namen. Ja. Seit der großen Tietze-Will-GmbH- Diskussion denke ich mir, wer hat entschieden, wie Romulus ist? Wir sind Obelix und Asterix.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Und der Erste ist meistens der, der die bürokratischen Kackaufgaben übernimmt.
Tim und Struppi? Ja, Tim und Struppi macht fast nichts.
Struppi leistet fast nichts.
Tom und Jerry?
Wird schwierig.
Wer macht den ganzen, aber Siegfried und Roy weiß ich jetzt einfach, durch unsere Historie, wer den ganzen bürokratischen Kackdreck macht. Ja, Siegfried. Ja. Entschuldigung, ich habe Sie angerufen, Sie sind der erste Aufnahme. Ja, was denn? Wir haben hier nochmal wegen dem Käfig. So, jetzt reicht's. Ja, so, Roy, du machst fast nichts. Du machst jetzt an. Das stimmt. Ja, wir hatten Wikipedia-Eintrag, Stimme auf das Kapitol in Washington 2021.
Wie lang ist der?
Ist das der beste...
Wie lang der ist? Also länger als...
Länger als unsere beiden...
So dein Arm.
Ist er länger als sein Arm?
Das ist schwer zu zeigen.
Länger als sein ganzer Arm?
Ja.
Das ist sein Unterarm.
Er ist so lang wie mein ganzer Arm.
Okay, das ist schon ziemlich lang.
Aber es ist auch sehr schwer, es ist keine gute Einheit zu messen für Bildschirminhalte. Ach, aber kann sich glaube ich jeder vorstellen, oder? Naja, so zwei, drei Scrolls. Ja, von meinem Laptop muss man auch dazu sagen. Werbung. Boah, Stefan, ich hätte Lust, ein bisschen gesünder und leistungsfähiger zu sein, aber ich habe keinen Bock, Sport zu machen oder meine Ernährung umzustellen. Hast du da nicht was für mich? Ja. Ja? Ernsthaft? Tatsächlich habe ich was für dich. Okay, ich habe es nur so aus Scheiss gesagt, aber wenn du echt was hast. Ich weiß, aber das ist ja, was wir alle denken. Und die Lösung für uns sind Athletic Greens. Denn bei Athletic Greens hast du alle wichtigen Nährstoffe, die du brauchst. Das ist die Nährstoffversicherung für den Körper, die jeden Monat becreme und einfach zu dir nach Hause kommen wird. Ja, da muss ich mir jetzt irgendeine Spritze ansetzen oder was, oder wie kriege ich das in meinen ekelhaften Körper rein? Nein, du trinkst es einfach. Löst es auf und trinkst es, es schmeckt sogar gut. Ja, es schmeckt so kräuterig, süsslich, aber eigentlich ganz gut. Aber kompakt geniesbar. Dann ist es wahrscheinlich viel Zucker drin, oder? Weniger als ein Gramm Zucker und es schmeckt richtig gut. Es würde nicht egal, ob dein Energielevel erhöhen willst, dein Immunsystem unterstützen willst oder deine Darmgesundheit überhaupt mal wiederherstellen willst.
Athletic Greens ist komplett richtig für dich.
Vielen Dank für den Tipp, ich schaue mir das Ganze mal an und falls ihr euch das auch anschauen wollt, dann geht einfach auf athleticgreens.com slash ufo und dann bekommt ihr sogar noch ein kleines Extra.
Ein Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3 und K2. Werbung. Hast du mal einen IQ-Test gemacht? Zählen die was? Bringen die was? Äh, nee. Ich habe Angst. Ich habe Angst. Mit dem IQ der Präsidenten der Vereinigten Staaten. Und die haben eigentlich alle so um die 140. Ja? Was, glaube ich, der Durchschnitt ist 100. Aber das ist auch so eine typische amerikanische Sache, so IQ-Tests. Dann Trump, habe ich dann versucht zu googeln, hat man nicht herausgefunden. Er behauptet selber, er hätte 156, was ich eine gute Behauptung finde. Aber Experten schätzen ihn auf 73. Warte mal. Und ich wollte die ganze Zeit zurufen, ihr müsst nicht so konkrete Zahlen nehmen. Es ist völlig okay, wenn ihr sagt, wir tippen es auf 80 oder unter 100, zumindest. Ihr müsst nicht sagen 73. Ja, aber ist 156 nicht auch genau der IQ von Martin, von den Simpsons? Von wem? Martin, der Typ aus... Achso, Martin. Martin. Aber es wurde mal in irgendeiner Folge wurde der IQ von Lisa und von Martin genannt. Ist Lisa unter Martin? Lisa ist unter Martin, ja. Doch, tatsächlich, leider. Darum ging es in der Folge auch. Lisa findet es raus, dass sie weniger als Martin hat. Nö. Wahrscheinlich wurde es irgendwann mal im Simpsons Comic erwähnt, die ich lange gelesen habe. Aber allein die Tatsache, ich finde schon skeptisch, wenn mir jemand sagt, meine Kuh ist irgendwas, würde ich sagen, mir ist egal, wie hoch deine Kuh ist. Aber warum hast du einen Test gemacht? Ja, weil du geringen Kuh hast. Nee, das stimmt schon. Kann man das in Deutschland überhaupt machen? Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Das habe ich noch nicht mal erlebt. Ich weiß es noch nicht genau. Weil ich finde das schon spannend, das zu bemessen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es wahrscheinlich auch wissenschaftlich nach wie vor wahnsinnig umstritten, wenn das bemessbar ist. Aber würdest du dann genauso, wie wenn du dann ein wichtiges Fotoshooting hast oder so, würdest du dann die Woche davor so richtig dich reinhängen und richtig lernen, so die Woche vor deinem IQ-Test, so wie du versuchst abzunehmen vor irgendeinem wichtigen Foto oder so? Ist das nicht die Idee von EQ-Test, dass man sich nicht darauf arbeiten kann, sondern dass halt nicht die Allgemeinbildung und so testet, sondern …
Doch klar. Versuchst abzunehmen vor irgendeinem wichtigen Foto oder so. Ist das nicht die Idee von IQ-Tests, dass man sich nicht darauf arbeiten kann, sondern dass halt nicht die Allgemeinbildung und so testet, sondern...
Doch klar, du musst da schon ein bisschen...
Kann man beim IQ-Tests bescheissen?
Na klar, natürlich. Du kannst ja irgendwas im Ohr haben oder irgendwie, tüge ich, muss mal auf die Toilette.
Und dann im Klo-Kasten sind die Antworten versteckt. Mein Gott, wir kennen die Tricks doch. Das ist doch jetzt wirklich nichts.
Da hätte ich richtig Lust, zu versuchen. Das ist eigentlich eine Fernsehshow eigentlich so. Wir können ja nochmal unser Talentpool aktivieren, den Karteikartenroller nochmal durchnehmen. Und zwar, fünf Promis werden in eine Sendung eingeladen. iCool zum Beispiel. Ja, können wir dann mal. Das Podcast-Ufo wäre doch wieder der Name. Ja, oder gut, okay, eins von beiden. Liegen beide auf dem Tisch. Und dann heißt es, okay, ihr fünf habt in zwei Wochen, gut, das Publikum ist schon da, aber man sagt, das Publikum ist zwei Wochen da. In zwei Wochen, jeder kriegt eine heiße Tasse Tee und ein Zelt. Und wir bleiben jetzt alles egal. In zwei Wochen habt ihr einen IQ-Test. Und ich will, dass ihr bescheisst. Jeder von euch muss betrügen. Und wer von euch den höchsten Wert hat, gewinnt dieses Porsche Coupé-Vierradantrieb mit einem riesigen Kofferraum, mit einem Anhänger.
Ein Porsche Coupé 260 PS mit so einem richtigen Pferdeanhänger.
Der gewinnt drei Pferdeanhänger.
Genau.
Aber so lächerlich gut ausgerüstet, so mit allem, was es braucht.
Genau, ihr seid wie so ein kleiner Zug. Ihr habt euren Porsche und dahinter sieben Pferdeanhänger hintereinander. Da sitzen die anderen Promis dann drin. Die anderen vier Promis sitzen jeweils in diesem Pferdeanhänger und die letzten drei, da sind dann auch Pferde drin tatsächlich. Und er hat aber genug PS, keine Sorge, der Porsche hat genug PS, dass er alle sieben Anhänger ziehen kann.
Und dann fährt er wie ein Zug durch die Gegend. Und dann müssen die Promis zwei Wochen... Ist das so eine Show? Nein, nein, nein, das ist der Preis. Genau, die müssen gucken, wie kann man betrügen. Der eine sagt dann, Jürgen Milski sagt dann, ah, ich habe hier einen Knopf im Ohr, irgendwie dann, keine Ahnung, Werena Baut. Der Bernatowiker bricht vorher ein im EQ-Testzentrum in Schreensberg und legt dann da in das Klo schon mal die Antworten, die es nicht gibt, aber gut, findet er raus. Irgendjemand versucht die Telefonnummer von dem Typen rauszufinden, der die Tests auswertet und versucht ihn zu bestechen. Jeder muss betrügen und dann am Ende nach zwei Wochen, wir lassen das Licht an für das Publikum im Studio, kein Stress. lüften zwischendurch, haben uns durch. Und nach zwei Wochen kommen die Umschläge dann, fünf Umschläge, die wir dann für die Leute. Mit den offiziellen IQ-Quotienten, wie man das sagt. Ja, genau. Also die haben dann den sogenannten IQ-Quotienten, bekommen sie dann ja amtlich ausgestellt und dann hat Verona Pohl 230, Albert Einstein hat 170, Dust for Scale, Bernard Hohecke hat 1009. Und dann muss jeder so einen Einspieler produzieren, wie er oder sie betrogen hat.
Und das Publikum hat unter dem Sitz fünf verschiedenfarbige Bälle liegen und zu jedem Promi gehört eine Farbe. Und sie müssen tippen, wer die meisten mit der Farbe den Promi abwerfen. Genau, in der Mitte des Schleusen sie müssen den Moderator abwerfen mit dem Ball, mit der richtigen Farbe von dem Promi, von dem sie denken, der gewinnt. Und dann alle, die tatsächlich auch den richtigen Promi kriegen, vier Pferdeanhänger mit drei Pferden, bar auf die Flosse. Und einem Esel. Und dann werden die langsam dann gebeten, ihr könnt jetzt das Studio verlassen, schalten langsam die Lichter aus. Das ist aber alles noch zu sehen im Fernsehen. Alles noch zu sehen. Die Sendung klingt sehr langsam aus. Aber es passt zum Mittelteil und zum Anfang das Tempo. Also finde ich ganz gut, dass es langsam ausklingt, weil es hat auch sehr langsam angefangen. Hört hier eigentlich irgendein Sendchef zu, der diese Ideen mal umsetzt? Ja, ohne Scheiß, ich verstehe das auch nicht. All cool werden die mal irgendwann gesammelt? Von irgendwem die Ideen? Wie ist denn unser Topmoderator nochmal? Wir müssen doch mal eine gute Idee haben, Guido Kanz. Guido Kanz, Guido Kanz, was hat der denn zu tun? Was hat Guido Kanz die letzten Monate gemacht? Ja, du hast es nicht so gewüten. Nee, der soll mal schreiben, was er gemacht hat. Anstatt unsere Sendung zu moderieren. Was war so wichtig im Leben von Guido Kanz? Ich habe jetzt immer gestorben. Auf jetzt, das sind die älteste Ausrede der Welt. Lass uns Guido Kanz mal einladen, wirklich. Und dann denkt er, es ist ein Interview. Aber nee, wir pitchen ihm zehn Sendungen. Wir pitchen ihm wirklich sehr viele Sendungen. Und er muss immer sehr höflich sagen, nee. Und vor allem ist es schon Teil der Sendung. Wie lange würde es dauern? Und es ist der erste Beitrag von Wie lange würde es dauern, bis Guido kannst, weil ihm zu viele Sendungen gepitcht werden, die Aufnahme verlässt. Genau, es geht wirklich von Tür geht auf bis er geht zur Tür raus, läuft die Zeit und Bernhard Hohecker sitzt hinterm Vorhang. Ihr habt ganz viele Bälle unter euren Sitzen versteckt, mit Zeiten drauf, von eins, eine Sekunde bis hunderttausend Sekunden. Genau, und diese Bälle habt ihr versteckt, die müsst ihr dann suchen, so kleine Bälle, weil wir hatten nicht mehr so viel Geld über. Aber Guido Kanz darf nicht merken, dass die Bälle im Raum sind. Sobald er merkt, dass ein Bälle im Raum ist, wird alles abgebrochen und die Sendung wird nie veröffentlicht. Also das ist das Risiko. Wie lange würde es, finde ich eine gute Prämisse, wie lange würde es dauern, bis Guido Kanz das Studio verlässt, weil er zu viele Sendungen gepitcht bekommt. Du, das ist nicht unmöglich.
Das ist möglich. 2021 können wir das machen.
Guido Kanz wohnt doch in Köln, oder nicht?
Ich würde fast sagen,
ja.
Niemand spoilert Guido Kanz mal gerade, bitte.
Und wir laden ihn ein
und timen und machen so lange
eine Podcast-Folge, bis er geht.
Wir bleiben die ganze Nacht. Uns ist es egal.
Uns ist es scheißegal. Die Frage ist, wie lange dauert es, bis er geht. Ihr dürft aber nicht gucken, wie lange die Folge ist davor. Aber ich finde es sehr gut, dass es die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass Luke Monk und einfach Fang im Fernsehen. Schneeballschlacht. Ja, das stimmt auch schon mal. Ja, natürlich. Und das ist doch die kreative Fallhöhe von wie lange würde es dauern, ist doch höher als Fang. Fangst die? Promi ärgere dich nicht, gab es auch? Und vor allem wurde Fangend auch verkauft in Cannes, wo ich da war, auf dieser Fernsehmesse. Da haben die Fangend verkauft, wo ich auch dachte, ist das euer Ernst? Wer hat die Rechte am Fangend? So, wo kann ich Topfenschlagen kaufen? Und dann so ganz viele Stellen da so, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier gehen. Aber so richtig maulwurfig, so richtig löst? Laufen ist gar nicht meine Disziplin. Gar nicht. Nee, ich glaube habe auch Asthma leicht. Ich habe einen ganz starken Husten, entwickle ich schnell. Ich habe eine ganz grauenhafte Kondition. Das funktioniert alles nicht. Wann bist du das letzte Mal so schnell gelaufen, wie du kannst? Das weiß ich nicht. Also wirklich so schnell, wie es geht. So den A-Knopf durchgedrückt bis zum Anschlag. Das ist eine superg gute Frage. Ich glaube, so achte Klasse, Bus.
Wow. Aber auch heute, wenn die U-Bahn losfährt, dann gibt es einen leichten Jog, aber nicht so schnell wie es geht. Mein Zeitplan ist ja viel variabler und flexibler. Wann hast du das letzte Mal so laut geschrien, wie du kannst? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, das mache ich häufiger für die Serien, in der ich arbeite, weil wir ab und zu mal so, keine Ahnung, im Ton so verschiedene Schreie brauchen. Aber so wirklich so laut du kannst. Schreie ich wirklich so laut ich kann manchmal, ja. So richtig mit und dann so laut du kannst. Krass. Ist nicht so laut. Läuft ziemlich laut. Aber das ist eine gute Frage. Wann hat das letzte Mal richtig schnell gelaufen? Weil mein Leben ist nicht mehr so, ich glaube, das kommt auch mit dem Alter, man ist nicht mehr so wahnsinnig fremdbestimmt, dass man nicht zumindest noch sagen könnte, oh, ich verspäte mich in fünf Minuten. Ja, aber man hat auch nicht so viel dran. Wenn du mal anguckst, so im Leben von einem Kind, das Kind rennt jeden Tag, so schnell es kann. Irgendwas passiert, Eiswagen, es rennt so schnell es kann, es will so schnell es geht. Und selbst bei dir, wenn das Beste passiert, was kommt, wenn dein Essen an der Tür da ist. Willst du nicht so schnell, wenn ich so schnell du kannst? Nee, nicht so schnell ich kann. Aber ich jogge gemächlich zur Tür. Und ist es dann so ein, was ich auch ganz gerne mache, ist, ich beschleunige erst ganz schnell und rutsche dann aber auf den Socken noch ein Stück. Ja klar, rutscht man ein bisschen, als wenn man rutscht die Socken an und man bewegt vor allem den Oberkörper so, als würde man rennen, was einem selber das Gefühl gibt, man würde rennen, aber eigentlich geht man gar nicht schneller. Man geht gemächlich hin, aber man ruht dafür mit den Armen. Es macht auch richtig Spaß, wenn du in einem Zug sitzt oder so,
wenn ich im ICE ganz alleine sitze, mache ich das,
dass ich so aus dem Fenster gucke und dann so die Arme bewege,
als würde ich so ganz schnell rennen.
Das mache ich nur, wenn wirklich niemand da ist.
Das ist dann schon ein bisschen peinlich, aber das macht Spaß.
Das macht aber echt Spaß, mach das mal.
Weil man fühlt sich so schnell.
Ich würde so gerne mal Menschen beobachten, einfach so einen Tag lang. Ohne dass sie es wissen. Ja, halt ist purer Voyeurismus, aber halt gar nicht sexuell gemeint, sondern einfach nur, was machen Menschen für weirde Dinge, wenn sie alleine sind. Ja. Ja. Menschen sind eklig alleine, glaube ich, richtig eklig, machen komische Sachen,
Fingerlanden. für weirde Dinge, wenn sie alleine sind. Menschen sind eklig alleine, glaube ich.
Richtig eklig, machen komische Sachen,
Finger landen schnell im Mund,
landen schnell in Nasen natürlich auch.
Es wird viel so weirder Kacke gemacht,
wo man dann so vorcrencht wie du, wenn du dann im Zug rumrennst.
Ja, viele Sachen fallen runter,
werden trotzdem gegessen.
Peinliche Sachen. So gar nicht, überhaupt keine Hemmung.
Ungeschickter ist man auch, glaube ich. Man gibt sich weniger Mühe, weil man weniger bewusst ist. Ja, wäscht sich nicht die Hände. Was ist das Ekeligste, was du jemals so alleine gemacht hast? Das kann ich nicht sagen. Das glaube ich, kann ich nicht sagen. Nee, das kann man auch nicht. Aber jeder hat einen Abgrund. Jeder hat einen absoluten Abgrund. Ich kenne das jetzt bisschen, ich habe in meiner neuen Wohnung, die sehr einsichtig, aber auch, was natürlich bei einsichtigen Wohnungen auch ganz nett ist, man kann auch die gegenüberliegenden Wohnungen sehr gut einsehen. Und dadurch hat sich jetzt so ein bisschen so ein offeneres Leben ergeben für mich, wo ich ein bisschen mehr aufpassen muss, was ich mache. Also ich kann nicht mehr so eklig alleine rumlungern, so einen Tag, so einen Sonntag, so einen Tüner alleine Sonntag, der ist nicht mehr so alleine.
Aber ich habe auch recht grosse Fenster.
Ich tue auch manchmal so, als würde ich Sachen machen, die ich gar nicht mache, irgendwie.
Also wenn sich die Augen treffen mit dem Nachbarn, dann auch mal Handy ans Ohr telefonieren, so einen Ordner aufschlagen und so mit dem Finger rein und dann so Sekunde, Sekunde, Sekunde, ich leg sie kurz mal weg und dann schneller blättern, ein Zettel rausholen, Handy wieder ans Ohr und dann, ja genau, also versichern bitte. alles versichert. Eine Put-Option auf Agatha.
Ich schaue ja gerade,
ich weiss nicht, irgendwie habe ich
es gibt manchmal, es ist ja so,
es gibt ja einzelne gute Filme, aber es gibt auch manchmal einfach Genres, die man mag, wo einfach alle Filme irgendwie gut sind, wo man auch genau weiß, der Film ist nicht gut, aber ich mag das Genre. Oder bei Agatha war es Agatha Christie? Nee, nee, aber mein Genre ist so Finanzzeug. Wirklich? Ja. Mein Genre ist Murder Mysteries. Nee, meins ist Finanzzeug. Wall Street. So Bad Banks, Industry kam jetzt raus von HBO, aber auch so was ... Big Short. Big Short, so was irgendwie. Ich verstehe kein Wort, was die sagen, mit irgendwelchen Shorts und Swaps. Ich verstehe gar nichts, aber irgendwie mag ich diese Genre. Ja, so Margin Call irgendwie, ich mag die richtig gerne, die Filme, so ernste Leute in Anzügen, die sagen, oh Gott, wenn das stimmt, wenn die Berechnungen stimmen, dann heißt es ja 200 Prozent Kurseinbruch und ich, was, das darf nicht sein, verhindert das, verkauft das oder macht was. Richtigst du dich auf dafür auf dem Sofa? Ja, ich rige mich auf. Das kann doch nicht sein, die müssen die Märkte regulieren, aber schnell! Keine Ahnung, was ich rede, nichts. Aber ich fange dann auch so an, so zu reden, ohne zu wissen, was es ist. Weil das ist interessant, weil es ist eine Welt, mit der habe ich nichts zu tun, aber irgendwie, die sind alle überarbeitet, die nehmen alle Koks, die hängen sich zu sehr rein und du musst mehr auf dein Privatleben achten und nein, wir müssen den Shareholder weniger steigern. Wenn du eine Serie und Filme guckst hast, wo jemand so richtig abgefuckt ist und Koks nimmt und die ganze Zeit trinkt und so und dann hat man die Serie geguckt und so und dann ist es auch schon spät, man will ins Bett gehen und dann guckt man so in den Spiegel und man freut sich so willig über die Augenringe, die man hat.
Man freut sich zwischendurch, wenn man dann sich so, man merkt, der Tag sitzt einem irgendwie in den Knochen, wie man sich darüber freut, wie abgefuckt man ist. Ich identifiziere mich so schnell mit Protagonisten. Das ist wirklich, ich kann das nicht gut. Ich bin sofort in der Welt dann drin. Ja, ich auch total. Aber es ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen so eine einfache Struktur in diesen Filmen. Wer viel arbeitet, ist sozusagen moralisch gut, was natürlich Quatsch ist. In der Regel kann man natürlich auch zu viel arbeiten. Aber das ist immer so eine einfache Struktur irgendwie so. Die hängen sich richtig rein, arbeiten die Nacht durch. Und dann so diese harte Hierarchie, so dieses, ich arbeite schon die zweite Nacht durch.
Ja, so ist das nochmal auf Wall Street. Hättest du dich je nicht bewerben sollen, wenn du nicht damit hart genug. Wenn du nicht damit hart genug. Oder Bären, wie auch immer. Oder die Wölf. Ja, die sind auch manchmal ein bisschen komisch geschrieben. Wie sehr? Der Hit ist beim Genre Murder Mysteries.
Also wenn man so eine Nacht in einem Menschen, in einer Mansion ist Anwesen und da kommen viele Leute zusammen und eine stirbt. Es kann nur eine aus der Gruppe gewesen sein. Deswegen Gathe Christie, Tod auf dem Nil, am Nil, im Nil, Tod im Nil. Wie heißt der Film?
Death on the Nile.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Detective Conan.
Detective Conan, finde ich auch, funktioniert auch immer ähnlich.
Fünfte auch genauso.
Immer irgendwo geschlossener Kreis, immer irgendwie von der Strasse ab, Schneesturm in irgendeinem Haus, werden sie aufgenommen.
Montemore Express, finde ich toll.
Sowas, Zug, kann ich anhalten.
Natürlich, Night Out, natürlich, Night Out, bin ich, einen tollen Film.
Bus.
Hat ja 2020 geliefert für dieses Genre nochmal. Clue, toller Film. Rakete. Vier Astronauten in der Rakete, einer stirbt. Was ist geschehen? Wer war's? Ich nicht. Doch. Ich auch nicht. Doch, doch, bestimmt. Okay. Dann tragen wir jetzt Schnick-Schlag-Schnuck-Kamm auf. Ist das hier überhaupt verboten? Ist Mord hier überhaupt verboten? So, das sind alles Fragen. Und was ich daran vor allem mag, ist, dass man in eine fremde Umgebung kommt. Meistens ist es ja irgendwie ein Haus. Dann verbringt man da quasi in Echtzeit, nein, aber einigermassen, anders als andere Filme, Zeiten mit diesen ganzen Charakteren, lernt man gut kennen. Meistens guckt man sogar als einen Charakter neu an und lernt auch die ganzen Leute kennen, wie der Charakter, verbringt dann da die Nacht und am Ende, wenn dann diese Auflösungsmusik kommt und der Mordfall ist gelöst und alle gehen nach Hause, reist man wieder ab. Das ist wie so ein kleiner Trip, den man da hatte. in einem abgesteckten System ja immer. Man verlässt dieses System auch nicht und das finde ich wahnsinnig beruhigend.
Also da irgendwie so sich einzuquartieren irgendwo und dann wieder wegzufahren mit einem gelösten Mordfall im Gepäck, das mache ich sehr gerne. Oh man, jetzt habe ich auch wieder Bock, Knives auszuschauen. Ich gucke immer wieder dasselbe. Ich glaube, irgendwann höre ich auf, einfach neue Sachen zu gucken und fange nichts Neues mehr an. Ich habe jetzt über Weihnachten nichts Neues geguckt. Nee, ich habe wieder Herr der Ringe geguckt, angeschaut, wie immer, alles ganz normal, viele Fragen offen, aber es ist okay. Ich habe wieder Star Wars geguckt, ich habe dann mehr Fragen danach immer als vorher. Also je mehr, je häufiger ich diese Filme gucke, desto mehr Fragen hat man dann irgendwie. Ja. Viele Sachen bleiben dann doch irgendwie unbeantwortet. Aber ist auch okay so. Ist auch richtig. Ist auch nett so, ist auch richtig. Trägt doch zum Mysterium bei. Fällt doch auf, dass diese grossen Filme und die grossen Franchises immer die Franchises sind, wo Leute auch Bock haben, in die Lücken reinzuschreiben. Also wo nicht alles übererklärt wird und es alles immer schon klar wird, sondern wo in Dialogfetzen Welten aufgemacht werden und keine Ahnung, plötzlich ist in Episode 4 ja schon vom Galaktischen Senat die Rede und so. Man fragt sich, wow, da gibt es irgendwo einen Galaktischen Senat, wo alle Alienwesen zusammenkommen. Das ist cool, das dann zu sehen. Das dann zu sehen ist dann lame, ist dann sehr merkwürdig. War auch cool auf eine Art. Das sind irgendwie so Politik-Dialoge von einem Zwölfjährigen geschrieben, wo man sich denkt, ja, okay, war nicht schlecht. Das dann am Rande mitzubekommen, so Kopfkriegen mitzubekommen, ist natürlich cool. Und diese großen Franchise macht das irgendwie aus. Bist du durch mit Star Wars? Bist du kein Star Wars Fan mehr eigentlich? Ich habe mich ein bisschen verloren bei den neuen Filmen. Jetzt Mandalorian habe ich wieder geschaut, fand ich okay. Natürlich die letzte Folge hat mich umgehauen. Keine Spoiler bitte. Keine Spoiler gibt es nicht, aber finde ich jetzt keine tolle Serie. Ist mir zu, ich finde es wirklich lustig, ist einfach mir zu Videospielmässig. The Mandalorian ist ein Charakter, der mir als Videospieler widerspricht, weil er die ganze Zeit nur Sidequests macht. Und ich denke mir immer, das ist wie so ein Bildschirm, du hast unten so ein bisschen deine Attacken, wie so ein MMORPG. Okay. Und du hast rechts deine Quests stehen. Und ganz oben steht, Grogu Rätsellösen, ihn zu seiner Art bringen, Slash Jedis, Jedi, und darunter hast du dann irgendwie so fünf Sidequests und der macht die Sidequests. Und der so, fuck die Sidequests, mach den Hauptplot. Und der ist dann auch wiederum, wie ich dann manchmal auch, wo ich selber nervig finde, da macht er irgendwas, damit er dieses Beskar bekommt, um sich eine coolere Rüstung zu kaufen. Eine coolere Rüstung. Der macht seine Rüstung schön, der macht seinen Char geil, aber er soll den Hauptquest mal lösen. Er holt sich eine kosmetische Lackierung irgendwie sowas für seine Rüstung, für eine 20-minütige Nebenquest und sagt, nein, mach das doch in deiner Privatzeit, mach das, während die Kameras nicht laufen. Das musst du doch nicht jetzt hier während der Serie machen.
Jetzt hat er sich dann diesen Stab gekauft, dann aus reinem Beskar.
Da muss er den erst lernen, irgendwie neuen Skill hochtreiben.
Legendärer Gegenstand, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. Ich will den Grogu Hauptquest haben.
Ja, stimmt. Es ist sehr questig.
Mir auch schon aufgefallen, sehr questig, jede Folge eine Quest, aber auf der anderen Seite, ja, wenn der halt jetzt irgendwie noch so spekulieren würde, so Aktien oder so, das wäre halt eher was für mich, dass der halt in so einen Hedgefonds investiert. Aber dann ist jetzt Star Wars Episode I was für dich mit den grossen. Ja, die Handelsföderation, die blockieren die Handelsrouten. Den der Besteuerung der Handelsrouten. Ja, gibt es keinen Cashflow mehr und dann stocken die Renditen. Genau, die Strafzölle, genau. Und dann muss er halt in die Rendite mit einarbeiten. Und Florian sitzt ganz vorne am Rande seines Sofas mit offenen Augen. Taschenrechner, aha, fünf Prozent Rendite, aber dann wie zehn Jahreszahl, das ist ja eine Rendite von neun Prozent! So schau ich mit dabei. Aber privat und finanziell, wie läuft das? Hau ich raus. Hast du den Bock? Ich habe einen grossen Eimer Kleingeld. Nee, ich meine das eher so, bist du in ETFs-Firmen? Nö, ich habe einen grossen Eimer Kleingeld und meine Anlagestrategie ist... Und einen kleinen Eimer Großgeld. Meine Anlagestrategie ist, ich nehme das Kleingeld aus meinem Geldbeutel und lege es behutsam in meinen Geldeimer und da bleibt es für immer und ewig, solange bis irgendwann der Boden durchbricht, weil der Eimer zu schwer ist, mein Nachbar tötet unter mir und dann ist das Geld weg für die Beerdigung und dann muss ich von null anfangen und dann mache ich irgendwie, dann baue ich irgendwie so ein Segelboot und fahre irgendwo hin und hole mir ein paar Fische oder so.
Finde ich super.
Das ist mein grosses Scheinjahr, habe ich auch vorgenommen. Segelschein will ich machen, Pilotenschein will ich machen. Ich will Scheine, Fischereischein. Fischereischein will ich machen. Ja. Den können wir zusammen machen. Fischereischein? Und wir begleiten das. Jetzt hat aber tatsächlich ein Freund von mir angefangen, Fischereischein zu machen. und muss jetzt immer diese, macht immer, hat das zum Geburtstag bekommen, zum Weihnachten und hat dann auf seinem Handy immer so eine Quiz, muss er jetzt machen, was für ein Fischsee ist das hier und dann viele Antwortmöglichkeiten. Es ist die Sürbe, die Wirsel, die Karsel, der Karselhering oder der Schlümpi und dann ist es halt eins davon und es ist einfach nicht zu machen. Und davon hast du so ein Tausend Fische musst du kennen. Idee, Guido kann es in The Shining. Fünf Promis müssen in zwei Wochen so viele Scheine machen, wie es geht. Egal welche. Jeder Promit macht einen Schein und begleiten die Promis auf ihrem Schein. Und am Ende müssen sie eine Aufgabe erfüllen, wo jeder seine Kompetenz braucht. Also der eine macht einen Förstereischein, Schneidereischein, Fischereischein, Fleischereischein und am Ende müssen sie irgendwas zusammen machen, wo jeder seinen Skill damit sozusagen reinbringt. Und die Zuschauer müssen voten, wer seinen Schein macht und wer nicht. Das ist ideal. Aber wo du gerade von deinem Einmal gesprochen hast, mit dem Kleingeld, ist ein sehr beliebtes Mittel von Drehbuchautoren immer, quasi nach dem Motto Show, don't tell, und man will jemanden charakterisieren. Ist immer schön, zum Beispiel ein Teenager, kommt nach Hause, vor einem harten Schultag, hat ein bisschen Kleingeld noch über, weil er von seiner Mutter dosgeschickt wurde, Lebensmittel zu kaufen, keine Ahnung. Und dann macht er dieses Kleingeld in so ein Marmeladenglas, das ist ausgewaschen. Und auf dem Marmeladenglas steht mit so einem großen Krepppapier, steht dann irgendwie Reise in die USA. Ja, Savings for Pilot School oder sowas. Und du weißt, aha, der will Pilot werden. Alles geschehen, kein Wort. Und dann steht genau drauf, was er machen will. Und es ist auch irgendwie niedlich, weil man unterstützt ihn sofort weil man denkt, oh, jetzt hat er da wieder so fünf Pennies reingeworfen. Ja, er hat einen Traum. Das ist ihm so wichtig, weil er einen Traum hat. Man liebt Leute mit Träumen. Ja, genau. Oder er kauft sich irgendwas nicht. Alle anderen kaufen sich einen Lutscher, so einen sauren Lutscher, den man so eintunkt. Und er sagt, nein, nein, nein, nein, no, no, mach ich nicht. Und dann fragt man sich, warum wollt ihr jetzt diesen sauren Lutscher nicht? Jeder will saure Lutscher, Leute lieben saure Lutscher. Zu Hause weiß er, Saving for Private Ryan. Und dann weiß man, ah, der will Private Ryan die Chemo bezahlen, dann doch. Oder irgendwie sowas. Wir sind ja, also, wer sind wir? Ich weiß nicht, warum immer Hollywood uns fragt, was für Ideen wir haben. Wir haben nichts. Wir haben keine Ideen. Was steht auf deinem Marmeladen-Jar?
Also ich glaube, mein Problem ist, meine Anlagestrategie wird durchkreuzt von Tradition.
Und zwar anscheinend ist es Tradition, dass man von seinem Kleingeld sich die Hochzeitsschuhe kauft. Also das war, wenn man so einen Eimer hat und ganz viel Kleingeld gespart hat. Es gibt ja so tausend Traditionen und Bräuche rund um Hochzeiten, dass man sich die Hochzeitsschuhe von Kleingeld kauft. Das heißt, sollte ich mal heiraten, tauche ich da auf in Jogginghose und Simpsons-Shirt, aber mit den fucking besten teuersten Schuhen, die die Welt je gesehen hat, zu vergoldeten Chromschuhen, weil ich einfach mein gesamtes Budget, das ich mein Leben lang angehäuft habe, in diese Schuhe gesteckt habe. In den Schuhen ist Tom Hanks, hat er seinen Abiball gehabt. Schwimmt Tom Hanks in so einem kleinen Wasserbehältnis? Schwimmt Tom Hanks drin, der kostet wahnsinnig viel pro Stunde. Aber das ist es wert. Das ist es wert. So kleine Promis. So winzig kleine Promis. Ich denke immer noch, wann gibt es endlich mal so ganz kleine Tiere? Wann kann man Giraffen so klein züchten, dass die auf dem Tisch so fünf, zehn Zentimeter hoch sind? Und dann laufen die so rum auf dem Tisch. Man kann die so nehmen und wo man sich hinsetzen. So kleine Giraffen. Dann kannst du so eine kleine Savanne bauen. Das wäre echt mal geil. Stell dir vor, irgendein Wissenschaftler hat irgendwie so eine kleine Tablette. Und ab dann kann man alles mit allem kreuzen. Also danach kannst du Giraffe, Miez, Gurke. Gurke, Miez, Schimpanse. Du kannst alles miteinander kreuzen und dann einfach go nuts. So jetzt wird nochmal alles. Und der Schimpanse so, I'm in a pickle. Er kann auch sprechen. Und du kannst dann einfach alles miteinander kreuzen. Und dann geht nochmal wirklich alles von vorne los. Evolution 2.0. Mantarochen mit Steinadler. Fliegende Mantarochen, mega. Ameise und Ameisenbär. So, das Crossover des Jahrhunderts. Und los geht's, go nuts einfach. Ja, Antilop und Löwe, wir wollen gerne wissen, was dabei rauskommt. Oh ja. Man kann einfach alles kreuzen. Eine Giraffe mit so einer Schildkrötenschild um den Hals. Oder so eine Schildkröte, wo so ein ganz langer Giraffenhals rauskommt. Das wäre einfach fantastisch. Und dann stirbt man und sagt, ne, bin ich schon tot. Fliegende Schildkröten, dann kommen wir auch Super Mario immer näher. So Möwe mit Schildkröten. Ja, es ist so eine Dimensionstheorie, dass wir irgendwann merken, fuck, wir nähern uns immer mehr Super Mario an. Dass irgendwann die Dimensionsphysiker, die theoretischen Physiker merken, verdammt nochmal, das kommt mir alles saubekant vor. Oh, hier kam das auch bekannt vor. Komm das auch bekannt vor.
Wir dürfen das nicht singen.
Nein?
Dürfen wir selber das singen oder ist es dann auch... Naja, das ist ein Rap.
Ach so.
Im Hip-Hop gibt es kein Urheberrecht.
Es gibt keine Cover im Hip-Hop, ne?
Dass Leute sich gegenseitig covern.
Du meinst Zeilen referenzieren?
Nee, weil so ist es ja üblich, dass Bands andere Sachen covern ist beim Hip-Hop. Ich glaube, es fängt so an. Ja? Ich erinnere mich auf jeden Fall so einen Auftritt von Emre, der damals bei unserem Schulabschluss Abibal, glaube ich, einfach Eminem gerappt hat. Und alle dachten, Alter, ist der gut. Alter, ist der geil. Der ist ja richtig gut. Da konnte man noch vortäuschen, was man alles kann und weiß. Und niemand wusste es, wie es wirklich war. Ich bewerte Coverbands immer daran, ob man wenn man bei Shazam auf Aufnahmen drückt, ob das dann kommt, das Lied. Wenn es kommt, dann ist es eine gute Coverband. Wenn nicht, dann ist es nicht gut. Habt ihr auch immer so geprobt? Ihr probt, ihr probt, ihr hängt euch hier richtig rein und Shazam Fragezeichen? Nein! Okay nein, wir haben geguckt. Okay, und nochmal von vorne. Mit so einer ängstlichen Stimme habe ich das einmal gesungen und Shazam hat einmal das Cover angezeigt von Africa und ich immer. Und solange das Cover zu sehen war, war alles gut und dann habe ich mich versungen ab und zu und dann kam das große Fragezeichen direkt und dann ist es einmal wieder zurück. Also super harter Druck und dann habe ich das einmal so gesungen. Ich glaube,, ich weiß, ich glaube, ihr lieben Zuschauer da draußen und Hörer vor allem, aber es gibt bestimmt Leute, die auch uns anschauen, das Logo anstarren, eine Stunde lang. Ihr wisst gar nicht, in welche Niederhöllen ihr mich werft mit euren ganzen Ohrwurm-Nachrichten. Die Leute schicken immer noch Ohrwürmer ans Reihen. Hier, ich habe hier einen Ohrwurm, Hilfe, was ist das?
Und ich muss mich darum kümmern,
und das ist schrecklich.
Und ich habe schon jede Song-Erkennungssoftware
der Welt durchprobiert.
Alles Crap. Alles Crap.
Alles funktioniert nicht. Aber es ging doch mal.
Ja, das glaube ich auch genau.
Es wird wieder schlechter.
Die Nelson-Mandela-Theorie.
Der Mandela-Effekt.
Die Nelson-Mandela-Theorie. Der Nelson Mandela Theorie, der Mandela Effekt. Die Nelson Mandela Theorie.
Der Nelson Effekt, meinst du?
Das ist ein Nelson Phänomen.
Das ist doch bei How To, ne?
Nein, es gibt doch was?
Bei der Serie How To mit John Wilson?
Ja.
Der war doch auch bei so einer Mandela Effekt Konferenz.
Ach so, ich habe das nicht auf die Folge an.
Okay.
Fuck. Eine Serie, die du mir empfiehlst, und dann will ich aufgreifen. Bei so einem Early Adopter, da gab es nur eine Folge, die habe ich geschaut. Danach habe ich vergessen, dass die Serie existiert. Das passiert immer relativ häufig. Der Mandela-Effekt, wo waren wir gerade? Der Nelson-Effekt. Ja, aber da vor, wo kamen wir denn auch den Nelson-Effekt? Ach genau, es gibt doch eine Software, gab doch mal eine Software, und immer wenn man Leuten sagt, ja, man kennt so eine Software, wo man auch immer miterkennen kann, sagen doch, es gab mal eine Software, wo man reinsummen konnte, relativ schlecht sogar, Super Mario. Es gab mal eine Software, die ist jetzt weg, und es gibt Shazam, und es ist schlechter. Ja, es gibt diese Software, das ist grundsätzlich schon, aber die sind alle grauenvoll schlecht. Es ist so, als hätte Shazam und es ist schlechter. Es gibt diese Soft-Fest-Konzerte schon, aber die sind alle grauenvoll schlecht.
Es ist so, als hätte Shazam diese Firma
gekauft und dann einfach
ignoriert, dass sie die bessere Technik haben.
Ja, aber das ist auch oft so, dass
bessere Technologien
klein gehalten werden. Wie in Foodora ist es auch weg.
Jetzt ist alles Lieferando und Lieferando
hat die schlechteste Drecks-App.
So, oh ja, jetzt ist der Stefan wütend.
Du, ich glaube, wir müssen sich mal ein bisschen entspannen.
Wie geil wäre Corona gewesen, wenn es noch Foodora gegeben hätte.
Ja, es wäre alles anders gewesen.
Dieses Känguru.
Was macht das?
Das war Deliveroo.
Die aussortierten Maskottchen.
Diese Maskottchen gehen in Rente.
Gibt es eine Rentenversicherung?
Wo sind diese Würfel-Rucksäcke? Diese riesengroßen Würfel-Rucksäcke?
Ach so, wird im Pen-Ofen-Drauch drauf.
Und das pinke Deliveroo-Fudora.
Wo sind die Fudoras und Deliveroo-Rucksäcke, diese grossen Würfel?
In der Wüste von Nevada so ein grosses Loch gegraben, wo die alle reingeworfen haben.
Kann man aus dem Weltall so grosse Babyblaue und pinke Kreise sehen, was so Halden sind? Ja, so von allen gescheiterten Firmen so riesige Haufen. Stell dir lustig vor, weil es waren ja im Prinzip riesengroße, weiche Würfel. Ja, im Grunde, glaube ich, kann man die auch gut weiterverwenden, irgendwie so zur Isolation von irgendwelchen Atomkraftwerken oder so, glaube ich. Die sind ideal. Können wir die haben? Ja. Holst du euch ab? Selbst ab Hohler. Nehmen Sie sich. Bedienen Sie sich. Ich nehme drei. Aber manchmal sind geschenkte Sachen auch nicht so geil. Ich brauchte für meine neue Wohnung, wo ich Vorhänge. Und dann habe ich überlegt, weil es gibt ja das Neo-Magazin nicht mehr, und dann haben die irgendwann den Vorhang aussortiert. Und dann habe ich so mal aus Spaß gefragt, ob ich den Vorhang haben kann. Und dann hätte ich dann den NeoShowvorhang als Vorhang bei mir gehabt, das natürlich cool gewesen wäre. Und dann haben die zu meinem Erschrecken gesagt, ja, nimm den einfach. Und ich dachte mir, what, wie cool ist das denn? Auch coole Farbe, so ein Graublau-Ding, bin ich hingegangen, der war einfach komplett eklig, zugemüllt, super, also so Kunstblut dran, halt ein Showvorhang. Ja. Super fleckig, also der sieht aus, vom Namen sah der so scheiße aus. Unglaublich runtergerockt, den konnte man nicht mehr benutzen. Und wie bringst du das ins Gespräch ein, wenn jemand bei dir ist und wie kommst du darauf? Die Blutflecken daran sind, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall ein guter Gesprächsrober. Okay, es sind Conversations da, da ja, und dann sagst du, oh, das ist ja vor. Aber auch ein Conversationender, in einem. Ja, richtig, stimmt schon. Ja, sprich, oft ist ja auch Schenken so die Vorstufe von Wegschmeissen. Es gibt ja viele Leute, die wollen nicht wegschmeissen, halte ich für selbstsüchtig. Die dann sagen so, nee, wirf das nicht weg, verschenk das. Nein, wirf's weg! Eine Freundin von mir, die schenkt mir immer Dinge, weil die die selber loswerden will. Ja, das ist richtig dreist. Das ist dann immer sauer, wenn man selber sagt, nee, ich will deinen Müll nicht haben. Dann immer sauer sein wie ihr, ich will dir das nur schenken. Ja, nee, nee, nee. Mehr wegschmeißen. Wenn das kein guter Tipp ist für das kommende Jahr, einfach mal ein bisschen mehr wegschmeißen. Ich glaube, es wird ein tolles Jahr mit Dutzenden und Hunderten Podcast-Ufo-Folgen. Davon habt ihr die erste gehört. Wir wünschen euch ganz, ganz viel Spaß, eine tolle Woche und lasst es euch gut gehen.
Lasst es euch gut gehen.
Einen guten Start.
Macht's gut, wem ab.
Wem ab, macht's gut.